[Music]
Kourtney Kardashian and Travis Barker
taking their next step I'm just like
living life and soon to be living in
some new digs a source confirms to E.T
the newlyweds bought a house and they're
taking the keys from another famous face
Conan O'Brien you uh ladies are very
Savvy about business the price tag
14.5 million dollars the house is
located in Carpinteria California just
south of Santa Barbara where Travis
popped the question
[Music]
according to TMZ it's over 2100 square
feet in boasts in Ocean View and if we
know this couple the house will be a
straight up love nest Travis and
Courtney are making outfits
this comes as ET learns details about
the couple's new chapter our Insider
says Courtney and Travis quote are
loving every minute of married life
they're pretty much Inseparable
meanwhile Scott disick's coming around
about his ex's new man
one of my chopped liver if you and
Travis are cool then we're fine
The Source reveals quote Scott is more
used to Courtney and Travis's
relationship now congratulations brother
thank you thank you congratulations
thank you and when it comes to the Blink
182 rocker The Source adds quote Scott
and Travis get along fine and there
aren't any major issues between them
[Music]
following Scott's appearance on the
Kardashians last week our Insider
explains quote Scott is still very much
part of the family and he talks to them
on a regular basis I mean I think you
just gotta figure out really what's
important to you at the end of the day
Scott in court Share three little ones
Mason Penelope and Rain Travis is a
really amazing father it's one of the
reasons that I fell in love with him he
is very very patient I think because
we've all known each other it does make
it easier to blend our families like
it's all I could ever want
and as our source tells ET the x is
quote still remain in contact and
they're co-parenting in a healthy manner
yeah I know I think they're doing
amazing and I think everyone has to
handle their co-parenting situation in
their own style but my mom and my dad
were like that it took them years but my
dad would come over once a week for
family dinners and would play golf with
my stepdad and so we come from a family
where we believe in that and you share
children with people and that's how it
should be
foreign